the company that happens in your earning
is just like the game of cash flow
basically with this little board game
where everybody starts at the same you
roll dice and you keep moving along the
board and as soon as you graduate high
school you had the option of starting a
job and start earning more money
immediately after high school or you
could go to college wait 4 years and
then make more money after that the
theory of the game is correct the fact
that nowadays college is massively
overpriced and undervalued and some
other career paths are as well doesn't
disprove the idea that the longer you
can delay your earning cycle the more
you are compounding your learning unto
itself